hurry to some media pronouncements the
United States did not need the 1 million
ventilators thus far that the media said
we were in dire need of in fact it's
encouraging to be able to say that every
single American who has needed a
ventilator has received a ventilator and
this administration has managed to
procure excuse me 100,000 ventilators to
be man manufactured in 100 days that's
extraordinary that's three times the
amount produced in the average year
likewise there was some concern about
m95 respirators but the Trump
administration has now shipped over 90
million in 95 respirators once again
that is more than three times the
average health care industry consumption
of in 95 restaurateurs respirators in
the typical year finally the u.s. now
leads the world in testing for weeks the
media cited South Korea as being the
gold standard for testing but as it
stands we are now testing at a higher
rate per capita than South Korea and in
fact as this chart is going to show you
in all 50 states we are now testing at a
higher rate per capita than South Korea
so a state in this country is testing at
a higher rate per capita than the entire
country of South Korea that's pretty
extraordinary I would say now I would
like to provide the American people with
an update on the Trump administration
support for underserved communities as
the president has said this country is
at war with the invisible enemy and
while we all fight the virus as one
United American people it is a fact that
this virus disproportionately has
affected those and medically underserved
communities and therefore the president
has committed to delivering economic
supports in quality care for individuals
and distressed communities the Trump
administration as I announced last week
distributed 12 billion dollars and
provider relief payments to 395
hospitals across the country that have
been hearted hardest hit by the corona
virus many of these hospitals were in
underserved communities and to ensure
even more funding to these communities
two billion dollars of that overall
funding was specifically targeted to
hospitals in purports
to the amount of care they provide for
low-income and uninsured patients
additionally the Trump administration is
investing nearly two billion dollars in
community health centers to help their
28 million patients and medically
underserved areas that receive care and
the testing they need that's what this
funding is intended for and additionally
there's 583 million awarded to a
thousand three hundred eighty five
health centers in all 50 states the
District of Columbia and the eight US
territories specifically geared towards
testing these health centers currently
provide a hundred thousand tests per
week and fifty-nine percent of the
patients tested last week were from
minority communities finally under the
Paycheck protection program the Trump
administration has done extensive
outreach to the community development
financial institution funds across the
countries these are known as CDF eyes
and they support revitalization and
distress communities in the second round
of PPP 100,000 loans have been
distributed to CDF eyes into m.d eyes
which are known as minority deposit
institutions these have amounted to
about 6.2 billion dollars and finally
570,000 723 loans have been issued to
smaller lenders and non banks and these
loans have amounted to twenty nine point
nine billion dollars President Trump
will continue to fight for the health
safety and economic well-being of all
Americans especially those impacted in
low-income communities in disadvantaged
communities and with that I'll take
questions yes yesterday said the US had
prevailed on testing but today we heard
from senators both Democratic and
Republican who say that's not the case
senator Lamar Alexander a Republican
says what our country has done so far in
testing is impressive but not nearly
enough senator patty Murray Democrats
have been you dramatically more testing
is unacceptable we don't have a national
teaching plan what's the White House
response well first I would notes on the
words of dr. Anthony Falchi which is
this we will have and there will be
enough tests to allow us to take this
country safely through phase one I've
sat in the task force meetings where
admirals hua has talked to governors and
literally pulled out his chart and said
governor X here was your plan and your
request for testing in order to safely
reopen I can assure you that that will
be satisfied this month so I have seen
those meetings take place I can assure
the American people in line with what
dr. Fauci has said we do have enough for
phase one by the end of the week we'll
be able to say that we've conducted 10
million tests you know we went from
doing 150,000 tests per week to now
testing about 300,000 that's an
extraordinary effort not to also note
that that's two times what we're what
other countries are doing when you look
at America's testing I'd say that that's
pretty impressive and that's a testament
to the work of this administration and
the hard work of the private sector
schools and also vaccines if you don't
mind
first of all reopening schools there
were a lot of questions today up on the
hill about when indeed that can happen
when will the White House and will the
White House issued guidance benchmarks
for various communities on when that can
happen and how soon that can happen
there's a lot of concerned parents as
you know across the country yeah well
you know in our guidelines to safely
reopen that that are data-driven it is
phase three or there is an outline to
beginning to open schools so currently I
direct you to our guidance that
currently exists and there is that CDC
guidance that is in the works that is
forthcoming that will provide additional
details okay vaccines the question was
asked when when and if a vaccine becomes
available regardless of income can the
president ensure that everybody will get
the vaccine regardless of income well if
the president will go to great efforts
to ensure that I don't want to get ahead
of any announcement on his part but I
would say this that when it came to
testing there was that same question
what if I'm uninsured and don't have the
ability to afford a test this president
before it was even addressed in Congress
called in the private sector and got
companies to say yes we will cover both
treatment and we will cover testing and
then eventually
that was inscribed into law um so this
president before it was even an issue on
the hill took great measures with
testing and he will do the same for
vaccines and I would just note as dr.
Falchi said on the hill today there are
eight vaccine candidates and on January
10th we received the genetic sequence
the 11th there was a plan developed the
14th development began and sixty-two
days later we entered phase 1 clinical
trials for vaccine which is the fastest
ever and dr. fell Chi's knowledge at
least so that's a pretty good pace that
I think we're on to getting that vaccine
pharmaceutical companies he met with
executives back in April will he work
with them encourage them to make sure
that vaccines are affordable to everyone
absolutely there's no doubt about it yes
we in this room I have a couple
questions first on reopening doctor
thought you today stressed many times
that reopening without following the
federal guidelines and the gating
criteria could lead to more outbreaks
and could turn back the clock this
president Trump's still believed in
these federal guidelines and if so why
isn't he urging states to follow them
instead of asking them to move quickly
to reopen well he has encouraged States
to follow the guidelines that still
consistently our recommendation today
that you should follow the phased
approach to reopening as outlined in the
data I do want to stress as the
president has stressed that we do want
to reopen this country because there are
consequences that run the other way when
we stay close down as a country and I
want to run through a few of those with
you a hotline run by the substance abuse
and mental health services saw a 1000%
increase in responses during April as we
kept this country closed epic status
said appointments for screening for
cancer of the cervix colon and breast
were down 86 percent and 94 percent in
March there are real consequences for
that I'm abraca
too I carry a bracket to mutation so I
was someone who was regularly screened
for breast cancer until I got my
mastectomy and when I went to my cancer
hospital for screening I didn't see as
many people in the halls and that is
quite frightening because the
consequence of that is this according to
the iqv ia Institute for human data
science
a total of 80,000 plus diagnoses of five
common cancers and the United States are
protected are projected to be missed or
delayed during the three-month period of
early March to early June which is why
this president has always said go to
your doctor do your screenings there's a
way to safely do this if you feel chest
pain go to your doctor we can't scare
people from going to hospitals it's a
consequence of staying close though and
people are scared they're scared to even
go to their doctor and there are
consequences for that and finally I
would just point out recent CNN article
from Friday noted a National Public
Health Group that warned as many as
75,000 Americans could die because of
drug or alcohol misuse and suicide as a
result of the corona virus pandemic so
there are consequences to us staying
closed and it's why I believe it was
Apes medical groups came out with a
statement eight medical groups noted
concerns that some people with symptoms
of heart attack stroke and cardiac
arrest are avoiding hospitals so it's
why I've said from this podium I think
at least two times today is the second
or third you've got to go to your doctor
we've got to encourage you this country
to safely reopen said it would be
nonsensical to test all Americans and
yesterday the administration celebrated
testing 2.7 percent of the population in
order to reopen 100 percent of the
country what amount of testing does make
sense to you and what's an alternative
to testing to track and contain the
virus to make people feel confident to
get back to normal sure we have to
engage in strategic testing which is
what our experts have always said look
you know yet admirals [ __ ] who said it's
a bad strategy to say that you need to
test everyone because testing a person
now just means they're negative at this
moment a point also emphasized by dr.
Falchi if you get a test today that does
not mean that tomorrow or the next day
or the next day or the next day you
might get exposed which is why we
acknowledge testing is not preventive
what is preventive is wearing this mask
what is preventive is social distancing
what is preventive is washing your hands
these are the measures we need to take
to safely reopen and then we'll use
testing strategically for contract
tracing purposes for example so that's
the way it should be used and deployed
and I stand by the comment that I made
earlier yes
could you speak just a bit about next of
Parana fire we're on the virus funding
the bill that the speaker is releasing
today what provisions are no-go for the
administration what can you get behind
look I won't get ahead of the President
and negotiating but and I certainly
won't condition any future legislation
on a certain proposal but I will say
that the president has noted a payroll
tax is something that he's looked at not
Conditioning it on that but noting that
something he desires to see in it's
smart policy in fact according to
Stephen Lauren art Laffer this means
quota every worker in America would get
a substantial pay raise and what is so
promising about the payroll tax is that
it's a regressive tax so the lowest wage
workers are in fact the ones who would
be most help because they pay more
payroll tax than they do income tax so
that's something the president's
mentioned not necessarily as a condition
I won't negotiate here with speaker
Pelosi but I encourage her to work with
the president help these low income
individuals get this tax cut that they
deserve Michael Pak has a confirmation
hearing on Thursday could you speak to
what the president wants him to do it
confirmed to change the way the voice of
America operates yeah I won't get ahead
of that hearing which is later in the
week as you noted the task force the
president the vice president said last
week that there'll be some new additions
to the task force and that those would
be announced on Monday we haven't seen
those names yet do any update on that
and whether there are guns going to in
fact be people added to the task force
yeah there will be additions but no
announcements on that just yet
Jeff st. Petersburg today from
ventilators Russian ventilators that
explode it I'm wondering whether you can
tell us what happened to the Russian
ventilators that were sent to the United
States and whether those ventilators
have been used and if not if they're or
so if they're being taken out of
commission okay that's the first time
area of that story so I don't have any
updates on that other than to note that
we are way ahead of where we should be
on ventilators as I noted in my opening
remarks 100,000 ventilators 100 days is
really good
no one has died for lack of events later
but that's the first time hearing of
that story yesterday the president
indicated that he might be communicating
with vice president pence by phone for a
while while the vice president keeps
some distance can you give us an update
on whether or not those two men are
going to see each other in person or
whether the I know the vice president
has been working at the White House is
he keeping his distance from the
president for a while
the vice president has made the choice
to keep his distance for a few days and
I would just note that that's his
personal decision to make that as to how
many days he does it again that's a
decision for the vice president yes I've
got a related question when is the next
time that we might see dr. Bergson dr.
pouchy here in this room giving us an
update on
kennefa status of the public health
regarding coronavirus look we've heard
from dr. Fauci pretty much the entirety
of the day he had a hearing as you noted
so you've probably heard from him more
hours today then than you've ever heard
from dr. foul to you you hear from these
experts regularly out on television and
you know we'll see the next time they're
up here in this capacity but they we
certainly have valued their time and we
continue to value their time it's been a
while since we've seen dr. Burke so for
example I mean she is the coordinator of
the coronavirus past force when when
when we see her and be able to get get
an update from her and be able to ask
questions of her yeah again you know I I
don't know when in this capacity you
will see her but I talked to dr. Burks
regularly in fact I talked to her just
before I came out here excited some
questions about some funny numbers I
heard from senator Elizabeth Warren and
she helped me to correct those numbers
which I'd like to correct here because I
think it's unfair to the American people
to give inflated case numbers and
mortality numbers because it leads to
those same Americans making the decision
to not get a mammogram to not have the
cancer screenings they need so I'd like
to just reveal to you some information
dr. Burks just shared with me Elizabeth
Warren erroneously said there were
25,000 new cases today in fact there
were less than 20,000 senator Warren
said there were 2,000 deaths in fact
there have been less than a thousand I
spoke with dr. Burks about that so I'd
encourage our Democratic colleagues and
all Americans to make sure we're putting
out there good information because it
does have consequences yeah
this department is considering bringing
federal charges against the two men
charged with murdering Ahmad r3
does the president think that's
appropriate look I'd refer you to the
Department of Justice statement which is
this that we are considering the request
to the Attorney General of Georgia and
have asked that he forward to federal
authorities any information that he has
about the handling of that investigation
will continue to assess all information
and will take any appropriate action
that is warranted by the facts and the
law and the president I've heard him say
it to me personally his heart breaks for
the family of a Matar burry and we want
to see justice in that case as the facts
lead us to that place yes White House
Office they also wear marks around the
West Wing except when they were seated
at their desks I can't help but make
this you want to learn more
no it's because I'm distanced from you
you probably have a hard time hearing
from me right now should I have a mask
on and that'd be muffled I'm delivering
information to the American people I'm
an appropriate distance away I had a
negative test today I had a negative
test yesterday and I'm in an okay place
yes Bonnie for his troops on an
offensive footing how could you come
thinking about that and what does it
mean for the u.s. little peace process
not that I'm aware of and I don't have
any new information on that yes
White House report on locations to watch
and with increased cases
you said locations to locations to watch
with increased cases as we've seen rates
spiking in several spots in the Midwest
included in Kansas City is this a
concern of yours
I did speak with dr. Burks about this
just before coming out and I think
you're referring to a document that was
put out that wasn't a White House
document it was a FEMA document that
looked at what was going on in the
Midwest and she made the point to me she
showed me a document that showed that
these are isolated outbreaks that where
there's specific instances and let's say
a meat processing facility or a prison
where we isolate that there's a problem
were able to contact trace and pretty
quickly resolve the situation she
pointed out that in Des Moines there was
a dairy county meatpacking facility and
that was a good example of where we were
able to do that so I would just say that
and this was a quote this is proof that
the system is working that were able to
identify what the president said our
embers and put them out on its the
system at work yes yeah you mentioned as
an example of the risk of not closing
people not going to medical appointments
but how do you extend that argument to
restaurants nail salons you know barber
shops and beauties are those things kind
of essential things you're talking about
what I'm talking about is we have a
phase plan to reopen and you can follow
those guidelines and the restaurants are
in phases and entertainment facilities
you noted are in phases as accordance
with declining cases but as a whole with
the totality of the circumstances when
you have a society that's shut down
people are locked in their homes and
they're isolated it leads to the very
suicide line increased calls that I had
noted it leads to drug abuse there are
consequences to eternally staying shut
down which is why you have to find the
balance which the President does in
consultation with expert advice from dr.
Falchi and dr. Burks and the taskforce
and he makes the best decision for
America going forward he made the right
decision to shut down the country at the
time he did because there were 2.2
million lives at stake and a lot of
American lives were saved because of
that decision but at the same time it's
a balance which is why we put out the
phased guidelines to reopening ask you
about a statement the doctor Falchi made
today he said I think we were going in
the right direction but the right
direction does not mean we
by any means total control of this
outbreak how does that square with the
president's statement yesterday that we
have prevailed over the outbreak well
the president made clear he was talking
about testing the fact that we can say
we're doing doubled out of any other
country the fact that we can put up that
graph that shows South Korea as a small
little red bar of testing per capita and
every bar beside it is an American state
or territory out doing what South Korea
has done and let's note that South Korea
was the gold standard for testing in
fact on March 13th the Washington Post
headline was South Korea is doing 10,000
coronavirus tests a day the u.s. is
struggling for even a small fraction of
that and here we are on may 11th with a
Washington Post headline the
administration keeps bragging that the
u.s. testing now is better than South
Korea's was a month ago so you can't
demand that we reach South Korea and say
that we're bragging when we do this is a
moment where the American private sector
succeeded this administration mobilized
that testing every state is better off
than South Korea at this moment and that
is a very good thing and something to be
celebrated because it's American
innovation at its best with 92 emergency
use authorization 'he's honest this
administration under President Trump
working agree with dr. Falchi that we do
not have total control over this
outbreak the president believes in the
phase guidelines to reopening which dr.
fouled she signed often off on along
with dr. Burks and we encourage every
state and governor to follow yes thank
you daily the president said on Monday
that Florida has so much testing that
testers are literally sitting around
waiting for people and that there is a
quote great overcapacity yet the reality
in the state is there are still
widespread criticism reports of not
enough testing in the Kaiser Family
Foundation ranks Florida 24th in the
country per capita when it comes to
testing so is the president being overly
optimistic about the situation in
Florida not in the slightest I was
actually in the Oval Office when that
discussion transpired and the governor
of Florida governor DeSantis who's doing
a phenomenal job talked about that there
were there was over testing ability at
these sites so there were extra tests
there wasn't enough demand there weren't
people showing up to use them all he
said that that had happened
some sites in the state he saw it
firsthand he's the governor of Florida
and that's a good thing and we were able
to fulfill governor DeSantis plan in
full that he has laid out as necessary
to reopening the state of Florida which
happens to be my great home state yes
does not support that
Kaleigh so is the president just
listening to the governor or is he
looking at the data oh he's looking at
the data as I noted to you Admirals wha
has a chart of every single governor's
plan and has said we will fulfill every
single governor's plan governor DeSantis
was reporting what he had seen a
distinct facilities are derived through
testing sites with the restarting of the
economies on both sides of the Canadian
and US border
you know how much trade between the two
sides are essential for communities can
you update us on the plans for reopening
and also a timeline for reopening the
border yeah no announcements on that
front
today yep so now with the release of the
transcripts related to out of ships
Russian probe this week is there any
information you can share with us as to
what the DOJ has shared the White House
on whether it is investigating Obama
administration
officials on this matter so I don't have
any updates on that front because that's
currently a DOJ matter but you did refer
to transcripts and I do think it's an
important moment to talk about what was
in some of the transcripts that were
released prior to today so not the
specific ones that you're asking about
but we learned from newly released
transcripts a few things we learned that
with some Obama officials were saying
publicly it was much different than what
they were saying privately James clapper
was out there saying that he had
evidence that this was worse than
Watergate when in fact a few weeks later
he was saying privately I never saw any
direct empirical evidence that the Trump
campaign or someone in it was plotting
or conspiring with Russia Samantha power
said I am NOT in possession of anything
I am NOT in possession and didn't read
or absorb any information that came out
of the intelligence community suggesting
collusion ambassador Rice I don't recall
intelligence or evidence to that effect
former attorney general Loretta Lynch I
can't say that if it existed or not I
don't recall that being briefed up to me
so it brings the question it brings the
question to light why then did we have
many years of investigating collusion
that these Obama administration
officials never existed they never saw
any evidence of but for three years the
American people were dragged through the
mud and told that their choice for the
president of the United States might
have been a Russian asset based on no
evidence of all at all this president
was exonerated by the Moller reports and
there are some real questions for these
individuals who are saying one thing
puts thing publicly and another thing
privately thank you so much I think I
got to all of you and we'll be back soon
[Music]
[Music]